what do you think about what he said
about gotti like he said gotti i know he
didn't say like he said i know god is a
killer
i think god he had a temper i
um
um
i think
john was more of a narcissist
i think a lot of people say well i don't
think he ever shot and well i put your
head in front of him
when he's holding the gun see what he'll
do i think he'll blow your [ __ ] head
off in two seconds flat if he wanted to
so to say he didn't pull the trigger can
he give an order
he can kill
for sure
i think he got
he had a temper and a half
um
i think there was a couple of situations
where
his neighbor there was an accident and
they killed a neighbor and the neighbor
disappeared and all that [ __ ] but i
think he was goaded into that
by his wife drove him [ __ ] nuts plus
he was sick about losing his child he
made a mistake
in my opinion
so when you do those kinds of things
when you kill outside the life for
reasons like that
you're going to be looked at in a whole
different light
like we talked about before
you're killing somebody an innocent
person
my son was hit by a car
my neighbor he's still i think he's
still alive but if he's dead he's 100
years old so that's the only reason he's
dead in other words i didn't kill him
i wouldn't do that but that's an
accident
so i don't know i don't want to label
john as
he loved
to kill
i don't think he loved to kill any more
than i didn't love to kill
he did what he had to do for the life
i loved him
i was attached at the hip with him
he turned on me backstab i turned on him
we played chess i checkmated
simple as that i have no hard feelings
towards them if we were alive together
now and i know what i know now i would
shoot him in the [ __ ] head in two
seconds flat boom right now right here
from the whole [ __ ] world straight up
you betrayed me i did everything for you
i got you out of every case i'm behind
and the government knows it every case
he beat i'm [ __ ] behind it
bribing people threatening people doing
all kinds of [ __ ]
making things disappear
killing people for you
wearing those nostrils together we're
brothers
it's your tape
it's you on tape
not me
and you want to sacrifice me
you want to help the government put me
away
so i i turned on him
if you turn on me i will turn on you
i don't turn on people i don't backstab
i don't [ __ ] people but if you turn on
me or you [ __ ] with me i'm gonna [ __ ]
with you or i'm gonna turn on you
i don't take it lightly and i'm i'm
aggressive
in that fashion right away
and that's what happened but i do love
him i feel bad how he died he died like
a [ __ ] animal in prison and this guy
talking about he looked like he'll [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] you know you [ __ ]
[ __ ] what do you know
what do you know how many people did you
[ __ ] put away did you bury did you do
you have any [ __ ]
shame or any [ __ ] grief sometimes i
felt bad they're humans no you didn't
feel [ __ ] bad you [ __ ] dick
you didn't feel bad
sammy some people may some people may
say
you know they call him the american
mayor okay and the streets of new york
if you you know ask regular guys that
are not in the life and you ask about
rudy
they'll say he cleaned the streets of
new york i felt safer because of
giuliani i felt safer because of what
rudy did yeah law and order gave me a
certain level of peace
i was living in that community i was
scared for my life i was scared of what
was going to happen and you hear these
stories you hear these stories being
told i felt that way okay i liked what
he did okay as a mate
got it so him cleaning the streets on
what he did yeah
you can boast about that all the [ __ ]
you want
you can even boast about being a cop
i know plenty of cops and agents they
have a job to look for me a bad guy and
put me the [ __ ] away i'm not mad at them
don't do that don't say that what the
[ __ ] you know about john gotti
oh is my opinion shut your [ __ ] mouth
in that area
boast about what you did boast about
what you did on 9 11.
boast about cleaning up the city
i'm with you you did that i agree
you were great
you were one of the better mayors
i'll have a whole conversation about him
mrs great mayor
i don't like his statements
i don't like his statements about
parents
our parents
i'm not talking about your parents i
don't like you
i'm not talking about what your parents
taught you i don't give a [ __ ] about
your parents
but and i understand how people feel
about it
now
they could those same people could
understand how i feel about it and if
they don't then [ __ ] dislike me
or do what you want
there's a two-way street with everything
in everybody
i talked to you the other night you're a
classy [ __ ] guy what you do
is in your life the people you have
around you
it's a class [ __ ] act
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]